- Lion dancing dates back to
the Tang dynasty in China.
It was really meant to
ward off the evil spirits
and welcome the good ones.
I am a 20-something-year-old millennial,
but I still hold this piece of tradition.
(drumming and shaker music)
Grab three rings and make three lines.
I was born and raised in Chinatown.
We do have a lot of the Chinese traditions
that they've come over and carried on
and passed on to us.
Lion dancing is really
important to Chinatown
because it is a traditional sport.
It's something that a
lot of people do come out
and they celebrate
around Chinese New Year.
Typically includes at
least two people per set.
In a lion, you'll have somebody
who plays the lion head
and then somebody who'll play the tail.
When you first some in,
you walk through the door,
you can't just pick up a lion head.
It takes about a year
for you to be able to
work your way up to that level.
Kung Fu is the foundation of lion dance.
Their stances and their leg
work is extremely important.
We're having you train in your footwork
and your stances, making sure
that you're strong enough
to physically hold
yourself through a routine
but also a lion head,
'cause a lion head is heavy.
It's typically anywhere
between 15 to 30 pounds.
(man drums rapidly)
Typically we teach different routines
for each of the lions just because
you never know which
one you're gonna play.
(drumming music)
You can see us lion
dancing in the streets.
Anytime where there's a community event
we'll usually partake in them.
In Chinatown a lot of people
are familiar with lion dancing
and they get really
pumped and excited for it.
So just the energy and
the atmosphere for me
is ten times better.
It's really important for all of us that
we are educated about lion dancing,
we do carry it on just because it is
kind of a lost art here in America.
For me, when I do have children one day,
I would like to pass
that on to them as well.
I think it's really important.
I think it's what makes
our family our family.
(string music)
(electronic beep)